under-the-sea vision can get weird
cuttlefish have w-shaped pupils and
mantis shrimp see many colors we don't
but scallops have one of the weirdest
visual systems of all these marine
creatures have up to 200 eyes and each
of them uses a mirror instead of a lens
to focus light researchers put these
eyes under the microscope and found some
amazing things the mirror is made from
crystals of guanine you may be more
familiar with its role in DNA but
crystalline guanine is also a highly
reflective material that can be seen
everywhere in nature from fish scales to
chameleons skin 1 in crystals
typically form into bulky prisms but the
crystals in the scallops eye form into
perfect squares like a telescope mirror
the scallops tiled squares create a
smooth surface which minimizes optical
aberrations the shape of this mirror is
also the key to unlocking another
mollusk mystery the scallop actually has
two retinas the upper retina and the
lower retina the upper retina cells fire
when a shadow crosses over the scallop
indicating a potential predator attack
and tell the scallop to escape but
scientists were unsure of what exactly
the lower retina did using simulations
the researchers were able to infer what
happens when light hits the mirror these
calculations suggested that the bottom
retina provides peripheral vision in dim
light of course 200 eyes receiving light
from an area only a few inches across
would produce a lot of overlap the
researchers hypothesize that there may
be some process in the scallops ganglion
that combines this information overload
into a single cohesive image but until
we know how their brain works
the scallops I will still be one of many
weird optics found beneath the sea
you
[Music]